So let's get going today.
And what we were talking about
last time is the discovery that
the atom was not the most basic
constituent of matter,
that there was a particle that
was even less massive than an
atom.
And that is the electron.
But today, we're going to
discover the nucleus.
And so this is 1911.
And this is Ernest Rutherford
in England.
And what he was interested in
doing was studying the emission
from these newly radioactive
elements that were being
discovered.
So the emission from radium,
for example.
What he did was he got a sample
of radium bromide from
his friend Marie Curie.
And what was known was that
this radium bromide emitted
something called alpha
particles.
And the exact nature of these
alpha particles was not known.
However, what was known was
that they were heavy particles,
that they were charged and that
they were energetic.
And, of course,
today we know what these alpha
particles are.
They are helium double plus,
a helium with two
electrons removed.
All right.
So he got this radium bromide.
And alpha particles are being
emitted from the radium bromide.
And he had some kind of
detector way out here,
which detected these alpha
particles.
And what he found was that at
the detector there were about
132,000 alpha particles per
minute.
That was the count rate that he
was able to measure.
And then, because he was just
trying to figure out what is the
nature of these particles,
he did this experiment.
He took a gold foil,
a really thin gold foil here,
really thin meaning 2^10-5
inches.
That's two orders of magnitude
thinner than the diameter of
your hair.
I've always wondered how he
handled that.
That is pretty thin.
But he put that in there.
And lo and behold,
the count rate that he measured
once this gold foil was in
place, the count rate was still
132,000 alpha particles per
minute.
It appeared that all of the
alpha particles that were being
emitted just went through the
foil right to the detector.
It didn't even seem like those
alpha particles knew the foil
was there.
The same count rate.
It doesn't sound like a very
interesting experiment,
but at that time he was working
with a person named Geiger,
a post-doc named Geiger.
The same Geiger as the Geiger
counter.
And Geiger wasn't too happy
about the results of these
experiments.
And in addition,
Geiger had this undergraduate
student hanging around the lab.
This undergraduate named
Marsden.
And Marsden was really excited
about doing science.
He just hung around there.
He really wanted to do
something.
And Geiger was,
jeez, what am I going to do
with this guy?
Geiger goes to Rutherford and
says I've got Marsden here,
he really wants to do
something, what should I do with
him?
And Rutherford said well,
okay, let's have him build a
detector that can swing around
that gold sample.
Let's have him build a detector
that will rotate around such
that the detector can be
positioned this way,
so that we can look for any
alpha particles that might be
backscattered,
backscattered meaning scattered
back in the direction from which
they came.
And Geiger said ah-ha,
this will keep this guy busy
and not in my hair.
No problem.
So he goes down to Marsden,
Marsden is all excited to build
this detector.
He builds the detector and gets
Geiger, okay,
we're ready to go.
Let's try this.
And so they put the radium
bromide there in this
arrangement.
They're sitting there at the
detector and they hear tick,
tick, tick, etc.
Hey, particles at the detector.
And they go,
oh, well, that must just be a
general background.
So what they do then is they
take this gold foil away,
so that presumably all the
particles are going in that
direction and they listen and
they hear nothing.
And they put the gold foil
back.
And they listen and they hear
tick, tick, tick,
etc., 20 alpha particles per
minute.
And they then pick another
foil, platinum foil,
basically the same result.
They go up to Rutherford,
they get him down in the
laboratory.
Rutherford's looking over their
shoulder, tick,
tick, tick, etc.
Hey, there are some alpha
particles coming off.
Not many.
Look at what the probability
here is of the backscatter.
Hey, that probability,
we can calculate that.
The probability is simply the
number of backscattered
particles, 20 (the count rate of
the backscattered particles,
20), over the count rate of the
incident number of particles,
132,000.
That probability is 2x10^-4.
Not large, but not zero.
There is something coming off.
And Rutherford was amazed.
And what he wrote later on was
that this experiment was quite
the most incredible event that
has ever happened to me in my
life.
It was almost as incredible as
if you fired a 15 inch shell at
a piece of tissue paper and it
came back and bit you.
So how does he interpret that
experiment?
Well, what he said is that
since most of these alpha
particles went right through
this foil to the detector,
that must mean that those gold
atoms that make up that gold
foil must be mostly empty.
So the picture is that you've
got this gold atom here.
And he knew,
roughly speaking,
how large that gold atom was.
He knew it to be about 10^-10
meters.
But what he was proposing is
that these helium ions going
through, these alpha particles
are just going right through
that volume because most of the
atom, --
-- and he knew that there were
electrons in this atom because
he knew about the electrons
already, most of that atom is
empty.
However, occasionally,
once in a while,
not very often but occasionally
these helium ions,
these alpha particles,
what happened?
Well, occasionally they hit
something very massive in that
atom.
And when it hit that massive
part of the atom,
it reflected,
it scattered back into the
direction from which it came.
And from knowing what these
scattering probabilities are and
from knowing roughly the size of
this atom and the thickness of
the gold foil,
he could calculate what the
diameter of this nucleus was.
And that number came out to be
about 10^-14 meters,
the diameter of this heavy
massive part of the atom.
Now, he called that massive
part, he called it the nucleus.
He called it a nucleus in
analogy to the massive center of
a living cell.
That's where that name comes
from.
And this number of 10^-14
diameter, that's a good number
to know, the relative size of
the nucleus.
All MIT students should know
that.
He also knew that that nucleus
really had to be positively
charged.
Why did it have to be
positively charged?
Well, because he knew that
these atoms were neutral,
he knew already that an
electron was part of an atom.
And so this nucleus had to be
positively charged.
And, in addition,
he made some very sophisticated
measurements of the angular
distribution of the
backscattered alpha particles.
And from those measurements of
the angular distribution,
he was able to back out the
fact that this nucleus had a
charge of plus Z,
where Z is the atomic number,
times unit charge e.
So his model is the Z electrons
filled this volume,
this sphere effectively of
10^-10 meters in diameter.
The electrons filled that up,
but somewhere in the center
there is something that is very
small and very massive that has
a diameter of 10^-14 meters.
Because occasionally that alpha
particle hit that massive part
so most of the mass of the atom
is in this nucleus.
Now, isn't this a great UROP
project for Mr.
Marsden?
What did he do?
He discovered the nucleus.
Fantastic.
I also want to tell you that
this kind of Rutherford
backscattering experiment here
is also the basis of the
experiment that was done to
discover the quark.
The quark which is the
elementary particles that make
up the proton,
the neutron.
Same idea.
There is a high energy particle
that comes into the proton and
backscatters from the quark
essentially.
That is an experiment carried
out by one of my colleagues in
the Physics Department,
Jerry Friedman and Henry
Kendall.
Henry Kendall has since passed
away.
But the same idea.
It's really the Rutherford
backscattering experiment that
was done.
All right.
Well, now it is time for us to
do our own Rutherford
backscattering experiment.
And the way we are going to do
that is we're going to be
scattering off of this lattice
here, this lattice of these
Styrofoam balls.
These Styrofoam balls are gold
atoms, gold nuclei,
and then the space around them
is where the electrons are.
So this is one monolayer of
gold atoms.
Now, this scale is a little
wrong.
The real scale would be if we
had a pinhead in the center of
this room and then the rest of
the room was the atom and then
there would be another room
10-251 with a pinhead in the
center of that.
That's the real scale,
but the fact that the scale
isn't right, that's okay.
We are going to be able to
understand the principle here.
And what we want to do is we
want to be able to measure the
diameter of these Styrofoam
balls or the diameter of those
gold nuclei.
And we're going to measure it
by measuring the probability of
backscattering.
And the way we're going to
measure the probability of
backscattering,
the way we are going to do
that, is we're going to take
these ping-pong balls,
and they are going to be our
alpha particles.
And we are going to aim them at
the lattice.
And we are going to have a
total of 287 ping-pong balls,
or 287 alpha particles.
And so the probability of
backscattering will be simply
the number backscattered over
the total number incident,
which will be 287.
So this is what we are going to
measure.
Now, the next thing we have to
do is that we've got to relate
this probability of
backscattering.
We are going to have to relate
it to the diameter of those
nuclei.
How do we do that?
Well, the probability of a
particle backscattering is
simply going to be the total
area of this crystal,
there's our crystal,
the total area of this.
Now, you've got to ignore these
aluminum blocks here because
this piece of equipment comes
from my laboratory.
And I pressed it into service
for this demonstration.
This has nothing to do with the
demo that we're going to put
here.
It's just structural because
this is my manipulator
puller-outer from our machine.
So you've got to ignore those,
but that whole area there is
equal to 2,148 square inches.
And now the probability of that
backscattering is this total
area of the nuclei to the total
area of the crystal.
And the total area of the
nuclei then is just the sum over
all nuclei, and there are 119 of
them here.
So i=1 to 119 of the area of
each one of the nuclei.
And so that is just 119 times
the cross-sectional area of
these nuclei actually,
which is pi d squared over 4,
and this is all over 2,148.
That's the probability.
This is the diameter of the
nuclei.
And now I am going to rearrange
that and solve for the diameter.
And when I do that I get 4.79
times P to the one half.
If I measure the probability of
backscattering by this,
measuring the number of
backscattered balls over the
total number we throw at it,
then I can calculate the
diameter of the nuclei,
the diameter of those Styrofoam
balls.
That is the idea.
Now, you're going to do this
experiment.
And so now the TAs are going to
give you all a ping-pong ball or
two.
Come on.
We need to distribute the
ping-pong balls.
Here's the deal.
What you have to do is you have
to aim to hit this lattice.
That's all you've got to do.
Then you have to watch your
ball, and you have to see if it
scatters back to you.
Now, what doesn't count is if
you hit these steel bars and it
scatters back.
That doesn't count,
okay?
It also doesn't count if the
ball hits the Styrofoam but it
continues going in that
direction.
Your ping-pong ball has to
actually scatter back at you to
count.
And then, when we get all done,
I am going to ask whose ball
backscattered.
That's what we've got to do.
Now, some of you aren't in the
optimal position to hit the
lattice.
I invite you to come down and
get a little closer.
That is okay.
Now, are you roughly ready?
Yeah.
All right.
But there is one other piece of
information that is very
important that I have got to
tell you.
And that is that only fools aim
for their chemistry professor.
[LAUGHTER] Okay,
go to it.
Watch your ball.
Okay.
Have all the alpha particles
been launched?
Yes.
Fantastic.
All right.
Now comes the moment of truth.
How many of you had an alpha
particle that backscattered?
Okay, so now I've got to count.
Keep your hands up because
there are some lights that make
it a little hard for me to see.
Anybody in this section here?
Yes.
One, two, three,
four, five.
Six.
Anymore?
Did I get everybody?
That's it?
Six alpha particles that
backscattered.
Okay, so now we have to
calculate some probabilities
here.
The probability of
backscattering is the number
that backscattered.
6 divided by 287 and that gives
me 0.021,
carrying one extra significant
figure.
And if I now take that
probability and I plug this into
here, I've already done a
calculation.
I got a table here.
I find that that diameter to
the correct number of
significant figures is 0.7.
And the actual diameter of
these balls is 0.8.
So you guys did a very great
job.
[APPLAUSE] All right.
This works.
That's how they calculated the
diameter of the nucleus.
That's it.
Nothing else involved in this.
That is the principle behind
how it was done.
Very simple.
That is the principle behind
how the quark was discovered and
the size of the quark was
revealed.
That is terrific.
Now, we've got the problem that
the scientific community had in
1911, 1912, right after the
discovery of the nucleus.
And the problem is,
now we know the atom has got a
nucleus, we know it has got an
electron, what is the structure
of the atom?
How does the electron and the
nucleus hang together?
In particular,
what we have to do is we have
to ask what is the force of
attraction that keeps the
nucleus and the electron
together?
We are going to talk,
here, about this classical
description of the atom.
And we've got to talk about the
force of the interaction first.
Well, there are four known
fundamental forces.
What is the force that is the
weakest force?
Gravity.
Absolutely.
What is the force that is the
next stronger force?
Electromagnetic.
Absolutely.
What is the next stronger
force?
Weak force.
And the next force?
Strong force.
All right.
The weak and the strong forces
here, these are intranuclear
forces within the nucleus.
That's what keeps the protons
and neutrons and the quarks
together.
For the most part,
the weak and the strong force
don't have an effect in
chemistry, with the exception
for beta decay,
for some radioactive elements.
That's where you need to think
about, in particular,
the weak force.
Gravity also --
Well, gravity actually has no
known consequence for chemistry.
It doesn't mean that there
isn't one, but it has no known
consequence for chemistry.
All of chemistry is tied up in
this force, the electromagnetic
force.
Now, what I am going to do is I
am going to simplify it just a
little bit and just call this
the Coulomb force.
And why I am going to do that
is going to be a little more
obvious when you get to 8.02.
But I am going to call it the
Coulomb interaction.
And we know what the Coulomb
force law looks like.
The Coulomb force law is the
following.
Say I have a positive charge,
which is my nucleus.
I am going to call that force
plus e.
And at some distance R,
R is the distance now,
between that nucleus and the
negatively charged particle,
which is my electron.
I can describe the force of
attraction between this electron
in the nucleus by the following
expression.
That force, which is a function
of the distance between the two
charges, is just the magnitude
of the charge on the negatively
charged particle times the
magnitude on the positively
charged particle over 4 pi
epsilon nought r squared.
Now, I am going to treat this
force, just for simplicity
purposes right now,
as a scalar.
I am not going to talk about
the direction,
but because this is a force
between a positive and negative
charge, this is an attractive
force.
This epsilon down here is the
permittivity of the vacuum.
It is in there for doing our
unit conversion correctly.
That is all I will say about
it.
Maybe you will talk a little
bit more about it in 8.02.
And then, finally,
here is the r squared.
That is the important part.
That is the distance between
the electron and the nucleus.
And what I want you to notice
here-- I don't need the screen
down yet.
Hello.
She just switched it?
Oh, all right.
Sorry.
It looks like I'm not going to
get to it, actually.
Thank you.
What I want you to notice here
is that when r goes to infinity,
what is the force going to do?
Zero.
When those two particles are
infinitely far apart,
you've got an infinity in the
denominator, this force is zero,
there is no attraction between
them.
But when r goes to zero,
what does that force do?
Infinity.
When r is zero,
there is an infinity large
force.
And in between,
what is happening is that the
closer the particles get to each
other, the larger the force.
The more attraction there is.
The more they want to be even
closer to each other.
All right.
Now, what this equation is
telling me is simply,
what is the force of attraction
between the nucleus in an
electron for a fixed distance r?
In other words,
if I were holding the electron
and the nucleus in my hands at
some distance r,
that equation would tell me
what the force was.
And you can bet that in order
to keep them apart,
I would really have to be
pulling like this.
You'd feel it.
But you also know that if you
let them go, what would happen
is that they would move toward
each other.
What this equation does not
tell us is how they move toward
each other.
It does not tell us how r
changes with time.
It doesn't tell us anything
about r as a function of time.
Although we know the force law,
we don't know anything from
that force law about how those
two particles move under
influence of that force.
And so what we need is we need
an equation of motion.
And the equation of motion that
was known at that time is,
of course, Newton's equations
of motion, Newtonian mechanics,
classical mechanics,
the mechanics that governs the
motion of all bodies around us
that we see easily and
astronomical bodies.
In particular,
Newton's second law,
F equals ma,
this force equals the mass of
the particles times the
acceleration.
And, of course,
in this acceleration term,
well, I think you know what's
in there.
In that acceleration term,
let me just write it out,
the acceleration then is the
change in velocity with respect
to time and the velocity is the
change in the position r with
respect to time.
So we have a second derivative
here.
What is in this force law is a
way to get r as a function of
time under influence of this
force.
So we take this force and we
substitute it in here and we
would be able to solve a
differential equation for how
those two bodies moved under
influence of that force.
And when we solved this
equation, we would know exactly
where the two bodies would be at
all times.
As long as we know where the
bodies were when they started
out, using that force law and
this equation of motion,
we could tell you what r would
be for all future times.
That's called deterministic.
That's classical mechanics.
Well, we're not going to do it,
but we could actually set up a
differential equation and solve
for what r(t) is using that
force law.
We could do that.
And if I did that and if I
started out the electron and the
nucleus at one angstrom from
each other, like they are,
roughly speaking,
in an atom, what would happen
is that that electron would
plummet into the nucleus in
10^-10 seconds.
If I solved these equations,
I would find that r would be
equal to zero and t equal to
10^-10 seconds.
We've got a problem here.
The problem is that this
classical physics,
Newton's second law and the
force law, it is predicting that
after 10^-10 seconds the
electron and the nucleus are on
top of each other,
they've neutralized each other.
We no longer have an atom that
has a diameter of 10^-10 meters.
That's contrary to our
observations.
This is saying the atom
collapses in 10^-10 seconds.
But what we see is that the
atom seemingly lives forever.
So we've got a big problem
here, as they did in 1911,
1912.
And the problem is that this
kind of classical way of
thinking does not predict our
observations.
It does not predict the fact
that the atom lives together,
it lives forever.
It says the atom falls apart.
So it could be that the Coulomb
force law is wrong,
or it could be that this
equation of motion is incorrect.
And of course what's going to
turn out is that this equation
of motion does not work for
electrons in atoms.
You cannot use classical
mechanics to describe the
electron within the atom.
We need a new kind of
mechanics, and that new kind of
mechanics is going to be quantum
mechanics.
That is where we will pick up
on Monday.
Have a nice weekend.